hey guys it is the 14th of December
today my name is Jess and you're
watching games bunnies the team working
on star wars battlefront is reallocating
resources to work on the next
battlefield project which is due out
next year developer dice are shifting
some of their developers over on to the
next title ins of Battlefield franchise
according to development director Dan
vanillin who wrote on his twitter now
that we've shipped battlefront and a
part of the team continues to work on it
I am moving on to another project the
next battlefield as for we can expect
from battlefield 5 EA confirmed that the
game would be returning to its military
style groups for the next installment
PlayStation Australia and New Zealand
boss Michael Ephraim admitted that the
ps4's first party line up hasn't been
particularly strong this year Ephraim
told games what games that have been
released to this year from destiny call
of duty star wars most of them we have a
collaboration with for additional
content if you play on PlayStation 4
we've worked very closely with third
parties this year because our ass party
lineup was not as strong as we would
have liked the PS Wars major exclusives
this year included a blood-borne the
order 1886 and until dawn Ephraim added
that he is optimistic about 2016 as the
ps4 will have street fighter uncharted 4
no man's sky The Last Guardian and gran
turismo commenting on PlayStation VR
Ephraim said the device was still in its
planning stages and sonia still working
out how consumers might react to it
System Shock 3 has been officially
announced after being unofficially
announced thanks to an accidental leak
from its developer last week the
countdown timer revealed last week has
expired and the game's web page now
features the game's title and an
artist's rendition of the series
antagonistic a I showed in you'll
probably want to pop on headphones so
you can listen to the mildly terrifying
audio file that is also featured on the
page where presumably sure dancers do
you think I'd forgotten you insect while
other side entertainment appeared to be
the title development studio
page does acknowledge night dive studios
LLC as the holders of the system shock
trademark night I've recently acquired
the full rights to the franchise a
survey on the mailing list link asks
participants to list their experience
with the franchise and asked them to
note their platform of choice as well as
their interests in virtual reality
gaming let me know down in the comments
if you be keen to play System Shock 3 in
virtual reality and be sure to head to
gamespot or we've got stories on ark
survival evolved and a brand new Pokemon
that is everything I have for you today
as always let me know what matter to you
and I will catch you same time tomorrow